hey what's up my name's samuel leeds
excuse the
outfit i've just finished a workout i'm
about to jump in the shower and then
i've got some property viewings
however i had to share what i'm viewing
today and
the crazy opportunity that's in the
marketplace right now with you
so look commercial properties okay
are plummeting aviva have just thrown in
the towel
and said they are no longer lending to
commercial properties
that's huge as lenders are throwing in
the towel
and saying we're not lending to
businesses that are wanting to buy
commercial buildings that is that is
pushing the prices of commercial
buildings down even more because now
people are putting out like i can't i
can't buy this building
i don't want to buy the building i want
my stuff to work at home
so they're just crashing meanwhile
residential properties over the last
year or so have been booming
and they're going to continue to boon
this year everyone knows that all the
economists agree
so if residential properties are going
up and commercial properties are going
down
what's the opportunity well the
opportunity is very simply to
buy commercial properties no one wants
to buy them
because no lenders are pulling out and
um
and all sorts so you can buy it on a
bridge
change its use and turn it into a
residential house
or residential apartments or whatever
and then refinance
and rent or sell so there's massive
opportunities at the moment
and i thought before i go i've got some
views today but i just had to share
the kind of opportunities that you can
do right now and if you want to know
more about this i'm happy to jump on a
call with you or whatever
okay or invite you down to one of our
mastermind sessions and we can
brainstorm and talk about the types of
deals exactly that you can do
um let me give you some i'll give you a
hypothetical example right now of this
house
and then i'm gonna give you some case
studies i'll tell you what i'm doing and
then
i want you to go do the same okay so
imagine for a minute
that this house okay
this is offices okay so there's there's
ten little office units in fact um
you know and it's being rented out as
officers that's not the case
it's not being rented out as officers
it's being rented out as um as a whole
house and i'm renting it
or at least my company is renting it
okay how much
rent would this place get as an office
block
well two years ago it'd be a lot more
than it is now
because now most people are working from
home i guess it's a little bit obvious
too
i'll give you a full tour real soon okay
i'll give you a full tutorial soon but
if you're renting this place as office
blocks what that um and the rent goes
down now which it has
massively i mean we were paying 25 000
pounds a month
for a little place in london that's how
much i was paying in rent
before lockdown now i'm not paying
anything i don't want an office my staff
are all working from home
and everyone's doing that even the
massive companies the massive companies
are saying
no i don't want to rent anymore all my
staff are working from home even netflix
their staff are working from home
so what's that doing to the rent on
commercial properties
well the rent is reducing massively how
are commercial properties valued
commercial properties are valued based
on the rent
so that means that the prices are
dropping meanwhile lenders like aviva
are pulling the plug
there's a massive massive crash in
commercial properties people say what's
the
what a house price is doing what a house
price is going to do
do you talk about the brick because this
could be a commercial brick
or it could be a residential brick as a
commercial brick it's dropping there's a
residential brick it's going up
so what do you do you buy a commercial
brick and then you change the use into a
residential brick do you need planning
permission to do that
not necessarily they have changed the
rules
they've recently changed the rules and
said that you can buy a commercial
property
and change it to a residential property
without getting planning permission
now of course this varies on on the on
the property
um it's not quite as straightforward as
that but it can be
so i've got i've got i've got students
of mine i mean i'm off right now to go
and view
a pub which is going to be a potential
pub conversion
and again if you take a pub pubs are
empty at the moment a lot of them went
bust
so you can buy them really cheap and
then split them up into apartments
and then push the value up crazy high or
you can buy offices
or warehouses there's so much
opportunity
i'm i'm i'm excited so right now i'm
gonna go and review a large
pub which will be attentional conver uh
potential conversion and because the
pub's closed down
planning permission's gonna be a dar
door a donald it's just sat there it's a
pub
people get all upset one of my students
ryan
from the uh he's like a pop star boy
band singer
and he bought a pub in benshum near
newcastle and he bought it for 130 grand
you probably saw the video we documented
it
and then he spent 240 grand on it and
then he refinanced it at 700 grand
pulling all his money out everyone's
getting upset oh he's ruining the pubs
the pub was already ruined the pub was
run down
the pub was um not hadn't been in use
for a year or two
it's not it's it's not taking away the
pubs or ruining anything
it's just changing its use and making
money as a result
so that's what's what i'm really really
really excited about that
i mean zuppler have predicted that this
year there's going to be that house
sales are going to increase by 46
in the uk that's crazy that's mad
so residential property is going to keep
on booming commercial properties are
going to keep on plummeting
the rich people create the rules and the
rich people are saying that um
um the the rules are saying that it's
easier than ever right now
to convert them to get planning i mean i
was with patricia
one of our students on the academy a few
days ago she's buying um
all kinds of stuff she's buying a hotel
right now she's turning a hotel
into a service department service
departments which is again it's a slight
change of use
um but i you just you
need to study this you need to study
what's booming service accommodation is
booming
and you could argue that's commercial
but it's it's it's a it's a part of
commercial that's booming
um offices are plummeting
absolutely plummeting so you need to you
need to study what's going i mean listen
the same wind blows on us all jim rohn
says but it's the setting of the sail
that determines the destination
right now there's a lot of wind okay
people are getting made redundant people
are getting blown all over the place
there's wind and you can either you can
be like oh it's windy and get blown
around or you can say actually
let me set my sail in the right
direction and fly to success
and and that's what i'm doing that's
what my students are doing if you want
to get part of that
um you know join me on the on the on the
samuel 365 mastermind
i'll leave a link below you can pay a
pound one pound and you can you can join
the mastermind
for seven days and it's 95 pound a month
and then every week you'll have a call
with me
we can talk about what's what in a small
group um
join me at the crash course you know i'm
running a tour next month
i'm i'm gonna be in london swindon
portsmouth manchester
uh london sold out london has sold out
so
get to birmingham get somewhere but get
on it take massive action two thousand
twenty years
2021 has got to be the year of massive
action a lot of people are going to get
rich in 2021
and 2022 and then in 2023 and 2024
people can go oh why didn't i do it
because you didn't take action you know
so take massive action
and also by the way if you want to tour
this place you wonder what the heck this
is
because i've got properties all over the
place around here but we rank
we rent them if you want to talk let me
know in the comments
and i will see you guys real soon peace